Response has been shambolic
and pathetic. The coup de gras. This guy I don't give a if you
leave by the way from the subject. If If this is the state of
your mind where you're like Let's go.
You're just so angry you're unable to give any examples. You're
like you're you're hypocrite your present. Go bro. I don't need
you. I don't want you. Y'all can leave. I don't give a [__]
What kind of chicken [__] is this? This guy goes
on stream, starts lying about me saying I'm grifting about lefty
audiences, doesn't have the balls cuz he's a little to come on
and actually have a conversation about these issues. Oh
>> Look Pisco talking about some drama stuff tonight that
maybe we'll check out real quick.
Just real quick. A little Pisco drama is a treat.
As a treat as a treat as a treat.
Where is it at? Where is it at?
Wrong DM.
Listen to what's being said. I think people actually start Hold
on. Hold on. Hold on. I think this where I got to start. I will
say the following.
I am not at all convinced by and I know I wouldn't be, right?
I'm made for me. The kind of [__] that is being levied
at me with respect to some of the opinions that I've held.
A that any of these opinions relate to my attempts to curry favor
with community. I think that's like no basis to say that whatsoever.
But also the character
and nature of the detractors. I don't really see them in disagreements
that often. And when they do
they fold
like little pretzels.
And so
I strat My strategy is going forward is not to back down from
any of these
My interest is focus more on Trump stuff, political stuff, legal
stuff. No
But um I'm going to
rule notwithstanding, right? The rule in the Discord is what
the rule in the Discord is.
I'm going to get significantly more
and demanding in conversations cuz I honestly don't think Oh
no. Oh no.
Oh no.
Nobody tell the judge about this cuz I think that was his precise
recommendation to Pisco. Pisco, start telling these that they're
instead of letting them off the hook. When Destiny comes on
and says, "Oh, do you think this is celebrating?" And then he
reads a whole bunch of totally comments.
You need to actually go actually You're a complete
You don't You don't go, "Oh, well, I guess like maybe you could
say that. I don't think it's quite that strong. No. Wrong. Wrong.
You are a You are a deliberately
dishonest
some word that I'm not allowed to say, but it rhymes with Mr.
Mouton, okay? Starts with an F and ends in a T, okay?
You're a deliberately dishonest person. I think my patience and
it is patience even though it's been um sort of
I think uh slimed as like I don't know. Perceived
uh weaseliness or something by exhaustively going through things
and like walking people through step one or two. It's going to
be a lot more
just like right to the point every single second. And so if you
want to have those conversations, I'm happy to do it. I'm going
to ask probably that you guys like when you get in like this
is for big boys if you want to do this conversation.
And um if you're not interested in that, you don't have to have
the conversation. You can continue like chatting what you want
to chat and within the rules of my Discord and within whatever
communities you are saying things.
But I don't think that it's respected
when people uh
are patient and nice. I really don't, right? I've been saying
for a while now. I think it is true
that like
>> People don't respect that. And for whatever reason it
doesn't get through. And so I certainly am not going to back
down from opinions I actually hold. I think that the
response has been shambolic
and
And it shows in the character of the arguments which are all
personal, not on the merits.
Um and when they show up they they fold
pretzels. Fold or just lie
Just totally like fabricate.
Ah, it's Yeah. It is what it is.
Well, that's going to be my approach going forward on those particular
issues. It has nothing to do with these issues. None of this
has anything to do with these issues.
All of this has to do with
other stuff, right? These positions I've had on two discrete
things. The song Global Intro where I just read an opinion and
Ethan Klein lawsuit. These have been my positions or at least
most of the positions that people take issue with. Or aspects
in which the Ethan one has changed a little bit. But by and large
this has been my position for months now. So none of this is
like new breaking news. And it relates not at all to it. And
my mission hasn't changed because of And I hope you guys if you
feel I saw there was there was one comment. It's absolutely unhinged.
It's really funny, but it like it gets
like to me like it totally shows the nature of
the response here. So I unsubbed you from you over the latest
coverage you had of Ethan's lawsuit. I previously defended you
against people that criticized you for simply examining his unhinged
filing and criticizing him over his attempt to save your company.
However, in the latest coverage you did you've thrown away most
of your values and morals in favor of dogmatically defending
the defendants of these lawsuits in such ways that you make you
a complete and utter hypocrite on now every previous conversation
with a maggot regarding Donald's legal woes. No explanation,
right? No explanation whatsoever as to what the hypocrisy is.
No explanation as to a dogmatic defense of these people. Dogmatic
defense. In what sense? Put the username on the screen, you don't
protect this guy. Put the username on the screen.
Hence, we're only examining the context of uh the justification
in which I'm absolutely describing culpability in some senses,
not just in sense that people seem to want me to say. Uh but
there's actually no dogmatism involved with these people. And
but but the thing is it's highly emotional. It's highly emotional.
Um and argues your own friend Hutch over this. You use all the
bad faith debate tactics to intentionally obscure each time with
each unneeded analogy parts of the actual case at hand since
you are smart enough to know that on facts and merit you've got
no chance in a debate on this subject. Not the case. Not the
case. Those analogies, those things are meant to clarify. And
first of all, I don't think Hutch feels any kind of way about
it. We're totally cordial. Um behind the scenes totally like
Christmas. Uh one of my friends in this party that we had was
like, "Oh my god, do you do a podcast with Hutch?" He's a long
time fan of Hutch. Um No No explanation of bad faith debate tactics
used. And Can anyone describe a bad faith debate tactic I used?
A bad faith debate tactic was me
>> Okay. He I wish he could just admit that the jump to
the moon thing, while not a bad faith debate tactic looked really
bad to a lot of people and just be like, "I understand why it
looked bad and I won't use that precise description moving forward."
That's the one thing where I'm like, "Okay, that looked really
stupid to like a lot of people who don't get where you're coming
from." You have like an external rule set brought in or you have
to have like the laws of physics accepted and then it's like,
"Why concede that?" Because it's just cuz if you say nothing
could possibly make you think this. It's just
He can even clarify and say "Technically I'm right there, but
I understand why it's difficult for people to understand why
I'm right there." I just want you to acknowledge that like people
would feel when they hear that like you're being crazy. They
should crazy making them.
I understand you're on the don't concede anything, Kilo. I understand
that. I'm telling you that isn't You don't even have to concede.
You just go, "I understand it sounds weird. I'm correct with
it, but I understand most people don't think that way, so I'm
probably not going to use that again."
Didn't have to say he's wrong. He just has to say like he has
to clarify and say like "I understand why that looked weird to
people or sounded weird to >> of possible plausible like
that's a bad faith debate tactic is to clarify what we mean by
words. Like no examples used
You have something to work Oh, why didn't he He should have just
let those recordings. I wanted to cover those recordings on stream.
And he was like, "No, don't." Well, sorry. People were like,
"No, don't." I asked his mods, not him. Not him. I asked his
mods. And they're like, "No, don't cover it." And it's like
Cuz I swear everybody who's trying to come in and talk to Pisco
and be like, "Well, instead of like doing the possible possible
versus plausible thing, why don't you do" and then they just
rewrite and present possible versus plausible over and over and
over again. Or they say, "Why don't you just entertain their
argument until later and then you figure out if it actually matters,
right?" It's like, "So just have a conversation going down a
blind alley for 10 minutes, waste your time completely and then
say, 'Wait, did you mean that like one in a million this happens
or that this could be the case that we haven't like categorically
ruled this out?' Cuz that's not very helpful to the conversation."
Anyway. >> First takes up all time to discuss which takes
that of which I do now hope and any and all Rob No types clip
and hit you over the head with whilst rightly accusing you of
blatant hypocrisy. No explanation about partisanship. In what
sense is this partisanship in for any party or side? This isn't
about like political view or expression. That's my whole point
that it's not about these
And it shouldn't be about these things. No explanation of hypocrisy
whatsoever. It is now simply a fact that Ethan Ethan had legal
grounds to the three defendants. Something I've never said he
didn't, right? Had the moral high ground on them too for all
the coordinated harassments their communities engage in. And
this I think is the coup de gras. This guy I don't give a if
you leave by the way from the subject. If If this is the state
of your mind where you're like >> Let's go.
You're just so angry you're unable to give any examples. You're
like you're you're hypocrite your present. Go bro. I don't need
you. I don't want you. Y'all can leave. I don't give a [__]
But the
Get the [__] out of here. Go back to whatever cult
you came from. And that's not necessarily DG. There's other cults
that love Ethan for no reason, okay?
Ethan's just a bad person. He been a bad person for a long time.
He goes on his little podcast and he uses a little oh G shocks
I'm just a goofy guy. He's not. He's like an actual harmful bad
person and has been for a long time and pretending otherwise
cuz he's like your favorite cute little guy on his little stream
is gay. You're a [__] loser. Shut up. Grow up, okay?
Grow up. Just grow the [__] up. Essence of all this
and what's been unveiled is this utter derangement on moderation
standards. That is so openly one-sided, so obviously ad hoc.
I don't even need to say the words. I don't even need to make
the comparisons. They make themselves. Um and and so that's like
everything. It's a state of absolute derangement and delusion
and I invite I invite conversations with all these people. Uh
I apologize to Pisco for existing and making it so to make me
the bad guy. All of these people have to maintain the standard.
And while that is not all that's going on here, I do think for
like the most for like the craziest
who are like basically lying about him, I do think that's the
case. I think that is what undergirds this is these people need
to maintain this position, right? And they happen to agree on
both the the I guess like the my community thing and the Ethan
thing, right? How keenly aware of the fact that this is a proxy
war is
Uh I think he's almost entirely aware
Like after stuff was getting brought up about me, well, I mean
he referenced it multiple times. He literally referenced it multiple
times, yeah.
You're really okay with him So he clarified this Kringel Kanish
and took that back and said he just hadn't looked into it.
He clarified this and said he didn't look into it. So why he's
banned from his Discord? I mean, okay.
Did anybody really engage in this in his Discord when it wasn't
like them actively fighting on stream? Like I don't I don't think
most people were engaging very often in his Discord.
Unless I'm crazy. I don't think so. At some point we might need
to get like a moderator involved so we stay on topic. I I challenge
you. I challenge all of you to take the time to actually segment
the conversations
and listen to what's being said. I think people actually struggle
with all right, we have some disagreement.
Hello, hello. This is Kolinda. Kolinda. Oh, [__]
You're coming out of the wrong ears. One second. Kolinda, how
are you? Can you hear me? Hi. Pisco audio issues. Yeah. Every
time. Hit me. Well, the last time I was here, if I recall. Actually,
you know what? If you don't mind and I don't want to spend too
much time on this because honestly I'm about as sick of it as
you probably are. I ask you a question about the Ethan Klein
lawsuit because that Loner had an interesting idea that he really
wanted >> Loner? I guess that he just yes, Loner. Loner
Box. >> Who's Oh, Loner. I thought you said Loner had an
idea. >> Yeah. No, no, no. Box. >> Okay, got it.
Loner Box, yeah.
Uh he had um he had an interesting idea about it. Um so I just
I just have a hypothetical for you, okay? Um and I might even
add a little bit to it. So you know how um you know how Ethan
called you a fake lawyer? He did that, didn't he? He did not
call
Kolinda is a Loner Box mod and frequent caller. Cool.
a a fake
I hope this isn't one of the people in Loner Box's Discord who
hates lawyers specifically, but I think he implied it.
Okay. Well, let's say that um He said I was like larping. But
but I think it's implied, yeah. >> that was yeah. Let's
say that Ethan decided to to do that um to like to continuously
call you that like to to to like literally call you a fake lawyer.
And like let's say that he he decided to cover you and react
to you over and over again continuously or like um comment on
[__] Like let's say that he would decide to go after
you as obsessively as they say that he goes after Hasan, okay?
>> Yeah. Um and then after that um you come out with some
video about something, maybe something related to him actually,
and he announces um to his stream and he's like, you know what?
Pisco, I hate this guy. He's a fake lawyer and we're going to
watch this video and I want you to come watch it on my stream
so that I can take all his views away him and because I don't
want him to make any ad revenue or money from this. And then
he does it. Do you do you really think that you wouldn't be within
your bounds to sue him for copyright infringement after he said
all that When you say within your bounds, When you say within
your bounds, when you say within your bounds, what are you referring
to? Legality, morality, or
I mean like I I guess what I'm asking is
would you would you would you want to sue him for copyright infringement
and also represent yourself while doing it so you could, you
know, as a [__] you to him? Is that something that
that you could see yourself doing? >> If you're asking
me whether practically I would file a lawsuit on that basis,
almost certainly not. But I'm assuming that's not what you're
asking. I'm assuming you're asking me like if I wanted to file
a lawsuit, would I be justified in doing so? I'm telling you
I I would I would probably more likely to do a DMCA thing or
something like that if I was really pissed about it or about
him doing [__] like that. But just be aware of what
question you're asking
You would like use the tools that everybody uses for this exact
issue? Oh, wow. That's crazy. >> Um because it might just
be obviated by some other predominant concern, which is I don't
want to file a lawsuit for some [__] I don't really
care that much about, which is him being petty towards me. But
if you want to ask something different, which is if I did, would
it be justified? Then ask that.
Okay. Dude, I really I hate to do this to this person cuz I'm
literally eating right now. I did, would it be justified? Then
ask that.
Okay. Sorry. I saw the turn up I message before I had to do it,
okay? >> it was Loner's question technically, so but I
thought that it was I thought it was a good question. What's
the question? I'm
The The question that he or the thing that he was getting at
was like um would you not be justified in filing a lawsuit against
somebody who had basically spent like the past several months
and actually if I guess to go further even add to it and like
every time you had a stream, his fans were showing up in your
chat and like spamming [__] or whatever. >> Yeah.
You know, like further it, yeah. >> You're asking is it
would it be justified on those on that view, right? And my answer
is if I didn't care about the underlying infringement or preventing
infringement, I think the answer is no.
I mean, would you care I wonder if you would like I don't know.
I kind of feel like you like maybe you might just a little bit
or like you might be annoyed at the >> There might be some
infringing There There might be some infringing that infringement
that I cared about. Uh but if I didn't care about the infringement,
if I don't actually feel like the infringement um matters to
me. In fact, if I want the infringement, I don't think I would
be ethically justified if that's what you're asking. Is that
what you're >> Okay. Um yeah, it is, I guess. >> Okay.
Uh because I can just This is so trivial because if we change
this to Loner Box and Hasan, everyone understands, okay? So if
the if you have seen Loner Box do reviews of Hasan's content
content in which he's like not doing much in the given moment,
right? I'm sure you've seen it. Um Okay.
I just saw a crazy frame. content in which he's like not doing
much in the given moment, right?
>> I knew I saw crazy frame. I saw I saw it, okay? I see
into the Matrix. I'm just like, dude, is there a better one?
I'm sorry. This is uh
That's crazy [__] You've seen it.
Yeah, although yeah, I guess so. I mean, Loner Box's reacts always
But yes, I understand what you're saying. You're you're going
to say that basically um technically like any react content you
could sue for copyright infringement. Is that what you're going
to say? >> not saying that you can sue for copyright infringement.
We're just talking now about the justification, all right? Um
the justification like if Hasan sued Loner Box for those instances,
you would say, right? It's not justified.
Assuming he didn't care about the infringement. Assuming he didn't
care about the infringement. Assuming
Oh, you use the Yeah, dude, the Pisco free streams are really
funny. He just he gets like really impassioned and then just
like blows up. And and he gets like yeah, very I don't know.
He makes funny faces. I'm like This is the problem with like
sometimes calling people ugly or something is it might seem like
I'm making fun of him or like he's like I genuinely just think
it's funny. I don't think he's like ugly or something. I'm not
trying to make fun of his looks or some [__] He's
funny. >> that he is saying, oh, I'm I'm only suing him
to to support the socialist Marxist revolution and all the proceeds
I'm going to do and you know he's lying or like you know, it's
to that end or something. And it's to protect the react community,
the socialist react community. If he said something like that
and if you didn't think that he actually cared about the copyright,
would you say, yeah, that's that's totally ethically justified
for him to sue my my boy Loner?
Um well, no, I wouldn't. But I would also add to that. I would
also say um that because it I would I mean, this is going beyond
the bounds of your hypothetical because I would say that what
Loner does counts as um um as fair use. And to be honest with
you, like >> All of it? All of it, you think? Um yeah,
most yeah, given the length of the video. >> That's delusional.
Oh, is that is that not true? Like is that not I don't know how
fair use >> I've I've seen Loner Box streams where he's
reviewing the content and like sporadically commenting in between
like playing a video game where it's Okay, it's a step up from
like a chair react, but on fair use grounds, it's Okay. You're
talking about stuff like that, okay. Yeah. Usually when he reacts
to Hasan, he has a lot to say. >> is all I'm saying. It's
not always. In the case in which he's not doing that, when it's
not fair use, that's the case in which we we want to examine.
And the the truth is and you know I want you to grant it. If
the roles were reversed, everyone would be on the opposite side.
You must agree with that, right? The 95% I won't say everybody.
95. Oh, you mean
all the people that are [__] on you right now. >> Correct.
Correct. If I was on his Of Cuz basically what she has to do
to come back from this is she has to go, the response is always
indicative of the fact that these people don't understand the
argument or are operating in bad faith. I think in this one it's
more that they don't understand cuz the response from Loner Box
and I think what would be the response from this person is cuz
she already included it once. Well, what if he was like really
unhinged and covering your stuff all the time and like was totally
like It's like, dude, well, okay, the first thing you do there
if somebody's covering your stuff all the time and they're really
unhinged is you do try to DMCA them, right? That's what you would
do first. If they maintain that their reactions are fair use,
then I personally think
that you shouldn't sue them. If their If their reactions are
on par with what you would do yourself or with what other people
would do, I don't think you should sue them. But if you don't
DMCA first, I think you're just trying to people over. You're
obviously just a
horse. And so what does that tell you, Kolinda? It's Kolinda,
right?
Well, no. I I know I understand like Yes. So >> I get it.
There was a It's not principled, right? It's not principled.
They are not principled. I'm principled, they're not. Cuz they're
they're inventing some they're inventing some about intentional
malicious siphoning and all that stuff. That's all made up. Yeah,
I mean like like listen, I'll be honest with you. I just wanted
to ask you that question cuz I thought that it was interesting
that Lauren put it to you. I'll be like I don't actually care
that much about this about the thing client. Dude, apparently
Raws using these for thumbnails and they're they're going off.
Pisco VDGGR.
It's funny stuff. Funny stuff. Funny stuff. I challenge all of
you to pick the time to actually segment the conversations
and listen to what's being said. I think people actually struggle
with it. All right, we have a stream stream
Hello, hello.
Oh, whoops. Sorry, I clicked on the wrong video cuz I opened
up multiple timestamps for Pisco.
I I appreciate that. No, no, that's fine. I don't have to care
about everything. This is why I ask people and I get glad of
this too, if they care about it. Because if you don't care about
it, that's that's cool. The thing is people do care about it.
They very very much care about it. The fact that they're talking
about it and they're so they're calling me Dank is porous. They
care about it. And the reason I ask if you care is because I
mean people will say they don't care. But the truth is Colander,
your lack of care is just be honest. It's because you don't like
these people. If you liked them, you would care, right? Um no,
no. I mean I don't I don't care that much about Ethan's motivation
and like I don't even know if like I support the lawsuits or
whatever. The thing that I care about within this whole thing
is the extent to which that Ethan has been harassed. And I'm
not saying that you're doing this what I'm about to say, but
unfortunately a lot of the people and I think maybe this is why
you got roped into this. A lot of the people who are supporting
or who are against Ethan filing the lawsuits or whatever are
people who are against it on the grounds that they also like
deny the severity of the harassment that Ethan has faced and
like the craziness behind it and the reasons behind that harassment
or they or they're okay with it because it they
Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope.
Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope.
Okay. I can I can meme about the skulls.
Me me me about the skulls wasn't my original position. When it
happened originally, I'm like, "Oh, that sucks."
It's really bad. And when the CPS thing happened, I was like,
"Oh, that's really
The meme has been that it has been used as a rationale or a justification
for all of Ethan's bad behavior for like 8 months
Like we're done, okay? We're done.
We're done with the skull costume industry and everything it
entails.
You get You get 8 months for free and now you got to pay. All
right?
I don't I don't think like I don't either deny the harassment.
What I deny what I think everybody denies is that we know the
source of the harassment or that holding these people culpable
like make saying these people are culpable for the harassment
is not something that
Right? That that does not That idea doesn't stand on its own.
So, think that Ethan is an evil Zionist genocide supporter and
that his wife is like the rater of Ramallah and all this other
insane like I I care a little bit more about like the way in
which everybody basically came at him
That's you, Kathy. She's talking about you right now. Because
if he did not tow the line 100%.
Yeah, cuz he didn't he didn't deserve that criticism, right?
He didn't deserve those kinds of attacks. No, I yeah. I don't
think that he deserved that criticism and I feel like it was
a waste of like it just I guess it said so much about the online
left if this was going to be their focus, attacking a liberal
over this dumb [__] instead of like trying to do
something But but doesn't everyone kind of know that lefties
are cooked on the Israel stuff and that they take these like
insane positions even with respect to people who are sensible
allies? Like they've always been against liberal Zionists, always.
This is not something that I think and and I they say vicious
things to liberal Zionists. I just don't understand what the
basis of surprise is for these kinds of unhinged views regarding
liberal Zionists or two-state solutioners who believe in Israel
as a Jewish state. That is like not new. That is as old as apple
pie. And so the basis of oh my god, they all turned on the liberal
Zionists. Yeah, the left is unhinged on this a lot of the time
and that shouldn't be a basis of surprise. Now, is it unhinged
and still wrong for them to do the kind of malicious attacks
where they're either lying about him or they're I I don't even
agree with snarking in the first place where you have this kind
of like obsessive focus on a particular person. I have no issue
saying that. But there's this thing where like two wrongs don't
always make a right, right? Just because and I think you would
grant this if they're lying about him, do you think that we should
lie back in response? Oh, no. I I don't I don't think that like
>> So just just knowing that a party is being wronged just
just knowing that a party is wrong doesn't resolve the answer.
That's what like there's two parts of the equation. First is
were you wronged and is your retaliatory action justified? You
have to consider both. And anyone who says that I don't really
care about the justification part, I just care about the initial
aggression and not whether or not the reaction is justified in
light of the initial aggression as to the means by which the
response is dictated and the target of the response, that is
just an excuse not to think. That's just being a coward.
Not I'm not nothing you, but like I'm saying people who say I
only care about I don't want to consider other things. They're
just being coward.
Who don't and it's the opposite of what they accuse me of, right?
You get plenty of bonus points for staying in line and for saying
all the right things according to whatever your the in-group
preferences of your specific community. I Facilitating snarking
communities for Hasan is morally justified because Hasan is bad.
>> opposite approach is like let's consider it even if
it off your own audience. So it's actually ironically I think
the opposite. And as you sit here, is there anything that I just
said that you disagree with?
Um I I mean not not like super a lot. Like I guess the main thing
that the main thing that's kind of frustrating where I sort of
feel for Ethan is like it's kind of like a question of well,
what the [__] is he supposed to do? How is he going
to stop these people from constantly cuz like the the level of
un You have to understand that that is a thought-terminating
thing. What the [__] is he supposed to do doesn't
justify any
Doesn't justify going after somebody not responsible. Are you
out of your
>> unhingedness is like it's it's off the charts, you know,
the CPS call, mailing skulls to his house, the doxing. And and
I mean like really the H3 star
Skulls! [screaming]
Dude, hold on. Who's got the clip of Pisco from the other night
where he he slipped on this and he did it. He slipped on it and
he did it accidentally and then he immediately was like, "Oh
oops oops oops." Who's got the clip? I know I saw the clip. Hold
on. Let me see if I can find the clip. I'll find the clip. I'll
find the clip. Where's the clip? I know the clip exists. Where
is the clip? Kathy, where's the clip?
Kathy, I know you've got the clip. Hold
I'm trying
to find it. Where is it? Where is it? Where is it? Where is it?
Where is it? Where is it? Where is it? It's somewhere here. It's
somewhere here. It's somewhere here. It's somewhere here. I swear
to god it's somewhere. I I swear to god I saw this
You guys know what I'm talking about, right? Somebody's like
talking about this and he goes Yeah, I know the CPS and the skulls.
I know. Or some [__] like this.
I think it seems like at least part of this lawsuit is him trying
to like find the H3 star snark mods. Maybe so that he can sue
them for something else. Although he did complain in the past
about the fact that they were like stealing his members-only
content and then like re-streaming it in other >> I I don't
understand that either because like okay. So if there's a justification
a purported justification that wasn't actually given in the video,
right? So what you're saying here what people will do is they'll
do this post hoc rationalizations of the lawsuits that aren't
included in the announcement of the of the video, right? So one
that they've done is the CPS call not included in the video justifying
the trap that he said >> he didn't. Yeah, right. So another
post hoc explanation is a discovery rationale not included in
the video. It's unclear to me A why we should credit an explanation
that isn't actually offered by Ethan and just give like potential
justifications. But even if I grant Hold on. Somebody may have
found the clip. Okay, it just got uploaded. One second. One second.
You think it would be justified as a exercise of a fishing expedition
to get discovery material on an unrelated case do the case initially
regardless Yeah, so no.
So sorry. I want to do this.
I've always wanted to do this.
Okay, so the CPS skulls. Sorry. I'm my bad. I mean that that
was they're going after him. They're they're saying all this
stuff. Yeah.
It's It's like seeping into the back of his brain a little bit.
>> It's so funny. >> Yeah, I mean that's the
So sorry. I want to do this.
I've always wanted to do this. So anyway, you're saying CPS skulls.
Sorry. I'm my bad. [clears throat] I mean that It's so funny.
Oh, oh >> even That's not Yeah, but like I said, I just
kind of like um like I'm not I I told you like I don't necessarily
have a a super strong opinion about like whether or not the lawsuit
was a misuse of the legal system or any of that stuff. I'm just
saying that like I don't know what the hell else he's supposed
to do to get these people to leave him the [__] alone.
Listen, I I I I I sympathize, but
Hold on.
Who fails to understand
that if you go after somebody
who is like tangentially related but not guilty of the crime
you're you're trying to like them over for?
You don't actually go after the person who did it. They're anonymous.
They're in the wind. How have you reduced the likelihood of somebody
else doing it by shooting a random person?
Like somebody vandalizes the autocratic
and he just goes to a school Excuse me. He just goes to a school,
picks out a kid and shoots him in the forehead and he's like,
"That'll be a lesson to all of you." Do you really think that's
going to stop anything? That's not That's not how [__]
works. And especially if those people already didn't like you,
you being an eminently Sorry, like a far less likable person
doesn't help you. It doesn't make it stop. If you're not going
to go and deter the people who are actually doing the conduct,
you're going to deter somebody who is less radical, you're going
to radicalize more people.
Who is confused?
Who doesn't understand this? It's not [__] confusing.
It's really easy to
You've watched it You've watched it play out in history a thousand
times.
It works either way. But just because there's no quote unquote
solution, doesn't mean that what you do is therefore justified,
right? Suppose that the only solution to get them to shut the
[__] up is to run them over with your Tesla. It wouldn't
make it justified. So, the lack of alternative Yeah, go for it.
Is there I'm just curious. Like, um
looks maxing chads up massive >> You know more about law
stuff than I do. Like, is there actually a legal recourse that
he could take that's not like some crazy [__] like
DMCA stuff? Like, I The other only other one I
That's not some crazy [__] like DMCA. DMCA is less
crazy than what he did. >> I think of his defamation, but
that doesn't really work or does it? >> to this to the
CPS call? Let's take each of the things, right? >> Okay,
so >> I I think I think honestly at this point, I think
that BadBunny Nauta could absolutely be sued for defamation.
>> Then why hasn't he? Definitely by Lonerbox. Then why
Wait, then why hasn't he sued him [clears throat] for
I don't know. Um apparently I I don't know if he's not in the
country, but
It's It's probably because he's not he's not in America. I think
he's in Argentina, but like here like Yes, it's easier to sue
these other people because they're domiciled in America. They're
in places where it's easy to do service of process, but there
is this thing called the Hague Service Convention, and Argentina
is a party to the Hague Service Convention, and you can absolutely
serve people in Argentina. >> I don't know that Uruguay
or BadBunny Nauta's in Uruguay now. >> You know this? You
know this? Yes, I do. Yes, I know this. If he's in If he's If
he's in you know, I'm not sure there might be some other process
that Uruguay provides for out of country people. Has he even
tried to look into that? I mean, if he has and there is no feasible
alternative I think I think the issue here is I can't remember
if this is Argentina or Uruguay. One of them BadBunny Nauta like
gloated about how like the penalties for defamation are capped
at something like $100 total damages.
And he's like, "Oh, go ahead and sue me,
I'll give you this 100 bucks right now."
Then that still doesn't help you, right? Because you have to
sue the people who are responsible for the thing. And on the
defamation case Yeah. Yeah, there could be a case depending on
what the statement is at issue. And I think that we should analyze
it when the argument is made. When the That's the thing, right?
Everyone brings up these other things like, "Oh, he's frustrated.
He can't get to these people." Well, let's talk about maybe what
he can do to get to those people, what kind of methods, but the
mere lack of alternative doesn't by itself justify everything.
And And that's not like No, I I know. I know.
So so so so so so So, talk talk me out. Like, you're saying you
don't have a strong view on this case. Do you have any view on
this case? >> Well, no. I
Do you have any view on this case?
Oh, on the case I mean, not
I mean, like honestly, I could go either way on it, but like
mostly I'm just tired of hearing about it. >> It's kind
of It's been a thing that I've been sort of popcorn giving out.
And I do feel bad for you because of the fact that people keep
coming at you and the way that you've been misrepresented, especially
by like people in DGG. I think that's kind of Oh, yeah. I mean,
here here was the position. The position was that when I said
at the start to Hutch, "Do you care about this [__]
issue?" that that was bad faith. That when I clarified between
possibil- possibility and plausibility, that was bad faith. When
I asked, you know, "Don't you have the burden to show that she
neglected her chat and read it and didn't chose not to moderate
it." That was taken as bad faith. All these things that if it
were done in a different context against a different target,
people would celebrate like, "Oh my god, he [__]
owned it." Like, and then the ascribing of He's He's just bought
his audience captured. Hopelessly audience captured by people
who have no [__] clue what a principle bone is, have
no idea how to maintain consistent positioning, um and and this
includes a lot of the commentary class uh who have examined that
video. And I encourage you to to go through that video and try
to see the examples of bad faith. Um it's it's so laughable and
preposterous. And uh I don't give a [__] I'm going
to keep speaking my mind, and if people disagree, the great thing
is they're allowed to come into stream disagreements and debate
it and actually debate it and actually see where he stands. I'm
tired of talking about this already. I In a sense, I am, but
I'm very debatable in that in in another sense. And here here's
the thing. If people continue to to question and undermine, yeah.
Haven't Haven't we Haven't we harassed you out of this yet? That's
not actually what she's saying, but it's what I hear cuz I'm
annoyed. I'm going to talk about it, and they can come into The
thing is, people come into the the disagreement channel, what
ends up happening is they say things like, "I don't really have
strong views on it." or whatever. "I don't really have strong
views on on what's on what's happening." And the people with
strong views don't come and don't talk about it. And so, I'm
looking for all the people with strong views on it. All the people
who say that I'm per se bad That's not true, but Pisko just doesn't
want to call these people liars, okay? Every single person
who has showed up to debate Pisko
has extremely strong views on this. And then when they realize
how
thin they are, how insubstantial they are, how they don't have
any reason to believe what they believe, and when they get blown
the [__] out, they go, "Well, I didn't really think
this is that big a deal anyway."
Good one. Good one, loser. >> want to say They have a perfect
opportunity to come and have a conversation. Oh, yeah. Um I mean,
like does um I don't know. Did Did Kafka have strong views on
it? No, right? He said it was He said it was morally neutral,
that because of apathy, he doesn't support it, and that because
he doesn't think it's in Ethan's benefit, he wouldn't advise
it. That doesn't sound like a strong view, right? In terms of
the moral implications. Both That That is a correct summary of
his views. And how was that He's also an attorney, too, so, you
know, I'm sure he probably has more information on this than
most than like I do. Like, he and he are probably on a similar
level, I'm assuming, when it comes to knowledge about copyright
and [__] like that. Um But the thing is, the copyright
case the copyright issue isn't disputed. It's They're strong
cases. What's disputed is my reason for talking about this at
all as though that makes any sense whatsoever given the uh the
the parties involved and what people are want to criticize, namely
the ethics of any given situation, including and especially lawsuits.
I'm actually going to say a step stronger every time,
Not only people sometimes consider the ethical justification
of lawsuits, they often do. And not just criminal cases, also
civil cases. Both sets of cases, people will
>> Wait, who's been talking about the morality of a civil
case recently? I forget. People have been talking I don't think
people do a civil case is very often. Certainly not a bunch of
the people who hop on Pisko's stream to discuss it, right? I
don't think. Yeah, I would I would say so. >> the ethics
behind them. And um I'm tired of actually around. I'm actually
now going to be more aggressive in taking these people on and
challenging, you know, their views about it. Uh And listen, you
don't have strong views about them. You're saying basically you
could be convinced one way or the other,
Um yeah, but I mean, I don't The thing is is that if someone
makes a good argument like I I don't know. I would probably have
to think a bunch about this. Mainly
Like I said, the main thing that I care about, and it's not even
necessarily related to the lawsuit, it has more to
Kafka last night on Food Shops called Pisko bad faith and captured
by his audience as well. Said roughly, "People said mean things
about me in chat, and he doesn't ban them. His community is out
of control."
Give me a timestamp right now. Give me a timestamp cuz we will
go watch that. I will laugh about it.
Uh give me a timestamp right now. Give me a timestamp. >> with
the harassment that Ethan faces and like the reasons behind it.
And he had said all that stuff about how we knew that the left
was going to be unhinged on this, but I mean, it's probably I
I don't know the extent or how much you knew about Israel-Palestine
before October 7th or whenever. Like, I knew a little bit about
it, and like I've since learned way more since October 7th, but
I feel like um I don't think It felt like everybody was taken
by surprise.
I feel like Pisko knew a little bit about Israel-Palestine before
October 7th. I think the way that the left reacted to October
7th and the amount of like the number I feel like if you knew
nothing about Israel-Palestine before October 7th, and you had
like an extreme reaction to October 7th, that's like a bit weird
to Like, to like in terms of what should be done afterwards with
no understanding of the conflict up until that point, that would
be weird if you came in were like, "This is what has to happen."
Maybe seeing the gorp that was produced from it, like the disgusting
um terrorist attacks and the outcomes,
like maybe that. Dude, I love I I love having an argument with
somebody where they're like, "Actually, there's no proof that
the Palestinians were like maliciously trying to kill civilians."
And then I pull up a video of a guy walking along with an AK-47
firing bullets into every civilian porta potty at uh at the rave
or whatever, that desert rave. It's like, "Yeah, yeah, they're
definitely not trying to kill civilians at all. There's definitely
no proof of that.
Why Why are they firing rounds into all these porta potties again?
Worried about one of these has like an IDF spy in it or I don't
know. >> more people who were cheering it on, um and like
it was the same thing with uh >> crazy [__]
going on with the Israel-Palestine situation. It's It's a lot
of crazy [__] It's It's It's It's It's It's It's
It's It's It's It's It's It's It's It's It's It's It's It's It's
It's a I am not surprised at all. Well, first of all, I think
that there's a there's this like lack of support for Ukraine
among a certain segment of either the tankie left or the very
hard left. And but that is totally consistent with the left's
um myopic and here when I Oh, I'll check this out, Rile. I'm
going to check out these other timestamps. the left and the hard
left, and I think totally stupid view of um international politics
related simply to to to imperialism and mainly through the the
lens of imperial aggression and colonialism, which I think is
a a limiting way to to see these conflicts. And oftentimes uh
a reli- Ooh, I'm not going to watch that far. Is this the same
calling where they talk about Dan? Like, you watch it from here.
Give me a second. Wait. What? No, not this one. Oh, damn it.
reliance on America bad foreign policy. And this is not at all
new. It's not at all new in the context Okay, fine. I'll just
watch it right now. Give me a second. This is um Kafka talking
about Pisko. and his YouTube cuz I didn't really want to have
that conversation. But if I was going to stick around, I was
going to talk to him about this where like uh the Pisco and his
YouTube chat and like these other communities around him that
are his communities are all incredibly unregulated, and he kind
of uses this like free speech perspective to say like, "Oh, I
don't want to tamper free speech." whatever, blah blah blah.
But it's like, "Okay, well, but these communities are yours.
They have your name on it. You have a like you should take responsibility
for them, and you should care about what's going on in them.
And if you did, you could make really good communities. And it's
funny because like he had a really good Discord and it started
getting really bad. So, all the good people from his >> I
mean absolute I mean absolute free speech. Wait, all the good
people from his Discord left and made their own. What? Where
did that happen? Wait, where did that happen?
Also, what part of what part of Pisco's Discord was like unhinged
or crazy? I His mods like banned people who were going crazy
in his Discord. I Like people got banned from his Discord really
fast.
I don't know what we're talking about here where it's like, "Oh,
you didn't moderate your Discord." No, but the mods moderate
the Discord. is no free speech, right? Like if you let any bad
actors enter your Discord server and like manipulate the community
and manipulate the culture, then at the end of the day all the
people who join in who are looking for a chill community to hang
out in will not stay there because it's already been manipulated
by whoever comes first, right? So,
Oh. or whoever
These people are such victims all the
time, man. >> you don't care about. So, at the end of the
day this absolute free speech notion is fundamentally very naive
when it comes to a content creator perspective, you know. >> him
not really seeing what his role is. Like he's a so he's a full-time
streamer. He wants to do this thing. Okay, he needs to start
taking responsibility and think about the intent that he has
when he's building these communities and he's choosing not to
do that, which leaves the door open for these bad faith actors
to come in to do these things that then out raise all these questions
in people's mind and then he's silent about a lot of that
Dude, the this is I think even capitulating on the Discord thing
is now These people are just going to lie and and say this [__]
about you. Uh by the way, this is 1 day ago. Pisco had banned
this drama from his Discord before this.
This this is just all lies.
Like you literally can't negotiate with these people because
they're actual
They're actual terrorists who are just like, "Well, I'm going
to go start a splinter Discord if you if you don't fix it. If
you if you make it so that other people can talk about their
opinions, that that's that's all wrong. This is so I'm going
to go make a different Discord. It's going to be better."
Okay, dude. >> stuff. And whenever he's confronted about
a lot of this stuff, he makes excuses for that behavior. And
it's funny because then you go and you look at how he looks at
What did any of these people say? He didn't make excuses. He
said, "What's the ought?" What's the ought? What ought I do?
What do I have to do? Give me the ought. Give me the
Um ban everybody who doesn't like Destiny is the recommendation
from these people. That's the recommendation.
This is what it all comes down to in the end. Just ban anybody
who doesn't like Destiny. Just you have to like Destiny here.
That's better. Very interesting question, Don Devil. He's saying
they left and made their own. How does he know? Is he in the
new Discord? Is the new Discord an actual splinter free uh splinter
free from Pisco's tyranny or just an organized DGG brigading
hub?
Be interested to know. What's up, Nacho Mama? How's it going?
Denims and he's like, "Oh, well, Denims might not have seen that
stuff in his chat in her chat. Denims can't control her community.
Denims can't do these things about her community." And I'm like,
"Oh, you seem like a person that does not really believe that
these content creators have responsibility towards their communities."
When I personally, at least, and I think a lot of other people
say, "No, actually you do have some level of responsibility for
the people that are around you because those people are within
your community and you have the ability to keep them in or kick
them out." And What's DGG's responsibility for Fancy Sloth and
his uh harassment perpetual harassment?
Is there like uh culpability there? This this argument has just
never applied in DGG chat, so I'm very interested to hear what
it will end up being, right? It's it Dude, I think I think it's
incumbent on you if you want to talk to these people to know
the examples.
Like just to resist the totally disingenuous DGG pressure, you
should know examples of some of the things they accuse you of,
that they engage in, and you should say clearly this is worse.
Obviously this is worse. If you want me to entertain this conversation
with you, have the same opinion, say that whoever allows this
thing to happen is obviously
um like a disgusting person who you can't con.
Conscience? Conchin? I think it's conchin. Um
Some people come to me and say, "Hey, this Cybah guy is like
evil." As I I've heard that Destiny did on Twitter just
And I'm going to go I'll have that conversation with you if you
want to ban Darius from your all of your communities.
Darius, the guy who showed up the address you doxxed somebody
at to fight them, ostensibly to fight them.
Yeah, I'm going to say that's worse harassment than anything
Cybah did.
That's facts. That's just facts.
So, if you want to performatively virtue
live up to the principle you're trying to lay out or shut the
[__] up.
So, here it is for Destiny. If you ban Darius from all of your
communities, I'll think you're operating in good faith. I'll
ban Cybah from mine.
Super easy.
There it is. That is in bad. Ban him from your chat. Ban him
from your Discord.
And we're all good. I'll ban Cybah
Good luck. Like him saying, "Well, she might not have seen it
in her chat." It's like, "Well, does she have mods?" Because
if she has mods, those mods would have seen it. And if those
mods didn't do anything about it, it's because she didn't tell
them to make sure that kind of stuff wasn't in her chat. So,
yeah, she did Even if she didn't see it, if she had moderation,
that means that she is still responsible because those people
are working at her directive and those people didn't do anything
about it. But let's say she doesn't have any mods. That means
that she's being incredibly irresponsible because now she's just
on the internet saying she's not worried about what harm it could
do, not worried about moderation. That's irresponsible. That's
an unethical thing to do in my opinion. So, like no matter
Yeah, but he's saying it's an un He said repeatedly it's an unethical
thing to But that that's a far cry from calling CPS, you. And
these people It's like an intractable problem. It's totally intractable.
There's just no solving it. There's literally no solving it.
Right? Like he's he's going to sit here and go and just lie about
Pisco's position. I I just can't.
I just can't, man.
how he comes to it.
Darius is men of society and society and Cybah is a concerned
citizen. I do believe in the Rose case Cybah is a concerned citizen.
Yes. Yep.
Ryle, you set it for Destiny? No, he set it for my channel. Although
I think Ryle also used to run like a
a clipping thing for Destiny as well.
that has his own communities where like in my opinion his moderation
and his, you know, intent around it is flawed such that it allows
for these kind of bad actors. I mean, you look at the way people
were talking about me in his chat. Very rude, very disrespectful.
They didn't get banned. You didn't get the way that Have you
thought about that possibly just being because of your ideas,
Kafka? Possibly like the arguments you were making. Have you
thought about this? Also, clearly we wouldn't want to be in a
chat where people in the chat say rude things about the streaming
guest and don't get banned, right?
We wouldn't want to do that. Could you imagine being in a community
where like sometimes the chat was mean to a stream guest and
they weren't banned?
Could you imagine? That would be crazy. I think you should leave
any community where that happens, Kafka. And I'm pretty sure
you'll do it, right? I'm pretty sure you'll do it, right, Kafka?
You'll leave any community where they say mean things about the
stream guest and they don't they don't ban them, right? For sure?
For sure, for sure. Maybe Doc So, maybe. It just depends. I
I think you basically have to
Like I want to rule against it. Like I want to rule I I don't
want people reaching out to anyone who's involved in the content.
Because I basically don't want to ever risk having one of you
reach out and then other people trying to hold me responsible
for your behavior even though you're an independent actor, right?
I don't like that. I don't want that. So, as a rule uh from now
on 100%. It like already would have been a rule before, but I
think there's kind of like there's an exception here for the
fact that there is actually like um
Like it's it's basically what I see as harm reduction.
Um but I basically am just as a rule just going to ban anybody
who reaches out in a similar fashion,
Not even similar to Rose, but just like basically ever cuz I
don't want people holding me responsible for it. If you want
to do that, do it somewhere else off from here. You can just
go. Ooh boy told me Jstark was a good dude and Ryle's vids are
what convinced me to join Kick to watch the lives. Let's go.
Tell more people. Huh. Tell more people.
Darius is a wussy that loves Destiny because they both love mentally
ill women and because Darius wishes he was
Uh yeah, this is like
2023 analysis, but yes. The whole true responsible anyway. Probably
they were already doing that. They were already doing that anyway.
Yes. Yes.
Still can't see any By the way, the original reason for the doxxing
campaign is that people around me were doxxing and harassing
people around Destiny. Still zero evidence of that, okay? Still
Let alone evidence that I could action on. Let alone evidence
that like even ties somebody in my community to somewhere where
they do allow doxxing.
I've seen none of this.
Still nothing.
And by the way, they started they started breaking down the actual
allegation into like, "Well, I heard that like uh I heard this
Ryle guy like sort of menace some dude in a Discord while he
was drunk. That seems pretty
I'm like, "Okay, that's not what you were talking about. That's
not somebody around Destiny. That was like internal community
beef that was solved. People apologized and it was solved and
we moved on. But hey,
it's just going to soften until it's that I do actually feel,
right? Slowly over time.
It like the allegation will just keep softening and softening
and softening and softening.
Will you harbor him around your Discord who's a known doxing
false accuser? I know I believe I believe Maro does have a video
of Zip Zip [__] 14-year-old
I think that's true, actually. And I would just like Zip Zip
to show me any evidence that is not true. For anybody who can't
tell, that was a joke. That was a joke. That wasn't serious.
That was a joke.
So Maro has CP? He does. But he's a white hat like Destiny. Just
in case the cops ever want to investigate Zip Zip, he's holding
on to it, okay? You got really defensive about that. Wait, who
got really defensive about that? Oh, I'll go through some of
those um those clips of Destiny another time.
There's some stuff here from Pisgo streamer going to go over,
but I know there are some some clips of Destiny that are out
there that are really really goofy. Maro had 17-year-old though.
Wait so
No, no, no, no, I don't think he said the 17-year-old.
He was he was flirting with the 17-year-old. He probably had
some content, but I don't think they were
Um he leaked those DMs to me a long time ago. But he's a young
and he's not a 30 he's not a 30-year-old.
I think he was 20, 21?
Which like is pushing it, but
certainly not uh
certainly not evil. Okay. Worse to 17-year-old to engage in race
play. I don't think that's true. The Is the Parapom person a
17-year-old?
I thought they were 18 when they did it.
I thought they were older.
I think the argument there was that they're brain damaged.
No? Let me guess, it happened on Discord. Apparently.
Apparently, apparently, apparently.
Concussed. How severe
was the concussion? You forget about the part where he made her
write the hard R on her teams. That wasn't the 17-year-old. That
was the fully adult 18-year-old.
I believe. I believe so. I believe so. Made her over the internet.
Over the internet he did it. Is this >> people and we're
talking about Hobbit follower or Zip Zip or even Destiny whenever
they talk to him, they're all incredibly disrespectful towards
those guys. They say really horrible things about them and Okay.
Well, you know what? I think it's horrible when I think it's
horrible
when
Zip Zip won't give the shoes back,
>> I think that's horrible of him. I think that's terrible.
I think that's truly terrible when Zip Zip won't give the shoes
back. That's [__] up.
He doesn't ban those people, doesn't do anything about them,
stuff like that. And it's all like, "Well, this is free speech."
And it's like, "Okay, well, like if someone came in and they
started talking about, you know, a bunch of very things towards
Straight Raid whenever she's on your stream, would you do something
about it then? Right? Would you do it if, you know, like you
can create scenarios where it's like you do see that moderation
is appropriate." Wait, don't people go Straight Raid all the
time? I do think saying just like degrading things should be
getting banned for anybody. People are to come in and joke about
like Destiny's penis. Which is very bad, by the way. Don't do
I would assume Pisgo's mods would delete that, right? I assume
so. >> in these other in these other ways, yet whenever
it comes to insulting the people that you're debating, for some
reason we don't care. Yeah, double standards, right? Yeah. Well,
that and it's not that just like he's just abdicating responsibility
and pretending like, "Oh, well, this is free speech." And like
again, that's like part of the whole like Like when I go on into
your community or go on your stream or go on Destiny's stream
>> Yeah, you love my community, dude. That's cute. I don't
get disrespected. I feel like people are very respectful and
they're very nice to me. And and not like they're all like glazing
me, but it's like I don't have people like calling me a fake
lawyer. >> Well, well, well, they highly respect you. Yeah,
they highly respect you.
But they don't but they don't glaze you to the point where it
becomes weird, right? If that makes sense. >> think I get
a res- I think there might be like some higher level of respect
in there. There is a basic level of respect where they're just
like, "Oh, this is like another person and I'm not going to like
just be outwardly just like vicious to this person for no reason."
And it's like I don't think that that's too much to ask for because
like if I had a community and Pisgo came in and people were like
even in like the current scenario, like the current state of
things, if I had a community and Pisgo came over and talked to
me and people were talking crazy [__] about him in
my chat while we were talking, I would specifically ban those
people and be like, "Do not do that. I'm not interested in that
kind of environment." And I'm okay if like I'm not saying like
you and people can't talk [__] about him if you don't
want to. I'm just saying like when it's in your community and
you're bringing someone in to have a conversation, it's really
weird to then like look down and see people like cussing you
out. It's like >> Cussing you out, being weird. Yeah, it's
like, "What the [__] am I doing here, right? Like
why am I spending time in this environment? This isn't good for
me, so all right. I have had I enjoyed the talk. I do need to
go. I spent longer than I thought." >> I wanted to talk
to you about Pisgo's double standards and analyzing Denims and
Ethan Klein and mind reading them differently. Like, "Oh, he
can't mind read Denims, but then he can mind read Ethan Klein."
I wanted to talk to you about that, but it's okay. You already
know about that. But like yeah, so Yeah, that's it. Um [laughter]
I was going to be taking a break until the end of the year, but
I made an exception to come on and talk to you.
my god, Kavka, I love you. Oh, thank you. I'm going to be off
>> Wow, just a thank you. Okay, all right. >> Yeah,
thank you. You don't love me back. >> for the Well, we'll
see, you know. What the [__] Okay, all right. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Okay, all right. >> if I win if I win, of course.
If I don't win, then I'm going to be purely spite based and I'm
and everyone is dead to >> What? Okay, all right. Well,
well, like what do you want me to do? Give you all my votes?
Like I I'm going to
Jesus. [clears throat]
So lucky I didn't say anything more Could have voice cracked,
could have been very bad.
I think it's really easy to understand Ethan's intent because
Ethan has described his intent as something that can't be possible,
right? He's described like conflicting He's used conflicting
reasoning to describe his own intent.
And like he yeah, he's laid out his intent. Denims has said the
opposite. What you're asking is like how do you know to go against
somebody's like reasoning or what they've said was in their mind
at the time? And it's like, "Well, if they've openly contradicted
themselves multiple times
I guess they're like, well, I think Denims is a lying [__]
so she lied."
Okay. I Okay. All right.
Anyway, that that was cool. I guess.
Sorry, we're back to the Pisgo thing for just a little bit. I
think I'm going to have to skip to other timestamps to get to
the other timestamps. >> politics where these people have
been around for decades. And specifically on Israel-Palestine,
I mean, the criticism of liberal Zionists is this is as old as
the conflict in many in many respects. Um And so yeah, I have
this is not like yes, October 7th absolutely intensified pressure
to the forefront in a way that we haven't seen Even the development
of technology. Um and I do put these kinds of delusional
views um on the extent of culpability by liberal Zionists on
the nature of the conflict. I view that as in keeping with um
a larger pattern of delusion on the issue. And um I think misplaced
misplaced aggression. Basically that anyone who signs onto the
project the Zionist project. But by which I I don't consider
myself in any respect a Zionist, but I don't think that liberal
Zionists um are the problem the way that a lot of these lefties
do. But that's just like not new. This is often been uh a a
Uh I had a discussion with somebody who's not a huge fan of mine
the other day. And this is one thing they brought up was like,
"Um I think it's a sign of like of a Kiwi Farms association that
you let that that that you like make fun of Destiny's penis."
And I'm like,
Do you think Kiwi Farms is the source of my knowledge of Destiny's
penis being
Cuz it's not. I'm so I it's not.
I wish I didn't have that knowledge. I wish Lav had never spoken
up about it, okay? Cuz despite what many people have done, I'm
not seen it. All right? But she's described it and that's where
I got the description from. Yeah, like that's literally the place
it came from.
Like how do you blame that on Kiwi Farms? It's like on my stream
where she talked about it. What the [__]
a way by which liberals in America have been ostracized and pushed
out in the conversation. Well, this person was trying to justify
why doxing me is okay cuz they were trying to argue that
me calling Mouton an F slur for him endorsing doxing me was bad.
And I'm like, "Okay, well, you have to have more hate for that."
And they're like, "Well, it depends on it depends on if you guys
are doxing people. It's like you you guys should you guys shouldn't
be doxing people." And I'm like, "Well, we're not."
Uh otherwise lefty communities. Goofy >> Yeah, okay. I
mean, I don't I You just said something about Zionism that I
kind of want to move on. >> It's like such
such an unreasonable standard that gets presented. It's like
so disingenuous. Many people many people suffered from this.
Many people suffered from this.
Bosch and Lav won completely. It's so insane. Bosch mostly. Feel
like Lav got harassed like to the point of losing her
Bosch won cuz he walked away. Isolated his community.
And then um basically just explained
Destiny's positions
forever with like one sentence.
She's like totally total critical hit. One hit kill. Okay. Everyone
of this guy's positions are spite based and he just like solved
him instantly with one
[__] nuts. >> to ask you another question cuz
I'm curious. Because I think that it was the
Austin came back. Who's Pisgo talking to now? Same person. Same
person. I think I don't think there's going to be anything else
great here unless I'm
I had to take care of something in DMs as well. But I did that,
so now I'm getting ready to move on to
I think Pisgo talked some [__]
Pisgo's talking [__] Match I think this >> It's
like I I think in the in the in the in the account So this is
like a full hour later [snorts] or something. >> in these
circles we'd call that a microaggression and I would say that
that's [clears throat] discrimination or
Yeah, um and like I mean there's other like such that he has
said too that like I would have to like honestly like I feel
like Dan is the one who knows like a lot about this, but the
>> Yeah, have him Hey, hey, so have Dan come on and tell
me all the horrible [__] about Hassan. In the meantime,
we can talk about the Ethan Klein thing. You think he's going
to do that? He's not going to want to do that. He's not going
to want to talk about >> can can you can can you tell me
why you think you won't talk about it? >> Listen, Dan,
if you're listening to this, okay, I think you're very
>> Listen, Dan,
you're not very I'm not going to say anything. I'm not going
to say anything. I don't want to hurt Dan's feelings,
I've been talking to a random person recently on
I shouldn't I shouldn't even do that. I literally me just going
like, "Hey, talk to Dan." >> That like this [__]
so badly. It's so funny that I just start throwing it in whenever
I can. So, I was talking to Dan the other day.
>> Dan came around my Discord the other
Had some things to say. Just everybody in his community is like,
"I can't believe you're doing this. You're talking to these people?
Disgusting.
That's not a responsibility I should be trusted with at all,
okay?
I I can't be trusted with that that power to just like with Dan
by saying I associate with him. That's not a power you can trust
me with. That's up that it was given it. All right? I don't want
it. I'm like Jon Snow, I don't want it. I don't
Why'd you give me this? All right, where were we? >> number
of people that were watching Nope, old timestamp.
Old [__] old [__] nips [__]
>> You're not a good debater and I think that's probably
why you don't want to talk to Pisco.
I [laughter] mean, I think he knows that he's not a good debater.
>> What kind of chicken [__] is this? This
goes on stream, starts lying about me saying I'm grifting about
lefty audiences, doesn't have the balls cuz he's a little [__]
to come on and actually have a conversation about these
He just called Dan a little [__]
Oh, [__] Says I'm audience captured by Hassan Tanki.
It's total ridiculous, total smear, and he's too much of a [__]
to actually have a conversation. It tells you all you need to
know. These are all lies that are being perpetuated and have
no bearing on what's actually in my mind. Yeah, I I I I get it.
Um, I understand. Um, like I mean, at least Destiny has the balls
to come on and talk to you. So, whereas um, yeah, no, I I just
I don't think that Dan is
Dude, Pisco
Pisco should correct that as well. Pisco should say, "Yes, he
has the balls to come on and talk to me, but not the balls to
be honest when he's talking to me. He just comes on and lies.
He's just full of shit." necessarily a great debater. I mean,
maybe maybe he'll do it if if like Loner would moderate or >> I
heard that he was willing to do it if if if if Destiny would
moderate, and I
>> Okay, yeah. Well, maybe. I mean, if I if I manage to
get onto Steven's stream or whatever, then maybe I'll bring that
or the next time Dan is on Loner's stream, maybe I'll say something
about it. I don't know. Yeah. >> Do it because
I find it funny that um, he actually has a closer connection
to the J Soc community than I ever did. Isn't that right?
Um, I mean, Pisco, can you not engage in this? Can you can you
not? Can you can you not do this?
>> Hey, you're close to J Soc. No, you're I
You're you're suspected of associations with the J Soc community.
How do you answer these accusations?
Kind of, yeah. Oh, I actually know. Yeah, I mean, at least
Yeah, yeah, he was. He used to go on
Okay, Pisco, why is he Why is this acting like he wasn't friends?
Why is he acting like we
didn't get along at all? This is such You know Rob Noerr still
thinks I was like totally on your side in the debate you had
with him. This is such Cuz I I remember that community a long
time ago like before all the [__] >> And and
and and remind me. He was on his stream sometimes. Did Did Destiny
joke and say that he hopes that CPS gets called on Ethan Klein?
Wait, did Destiny
By the way, this community literally just shifted like the primary
target of of laughing at from Hassan to Destiny, and otherwise
it is essentially the exact same like wall to wall the whole
In terms of content focus.
And all these people are like, "This stream really changed."
Uh, there's kind of like I would say maybe just a lack of a co-host,
but otherwise it's just a target shift to Destiny instead of
Hassan in terms of By the way, never ever filling up like 80%
of the content or anything. It's like 40% of the content at most
in like a given week. And most weeks it's like 20% at tops. So,
I don't know. Like
people are acting like it's just crazy. I easily in the past
like 3 months have covered Nick Fuentes like twice as much as
I've covered anyone else.
Like the right-wing civil war. So, I don't know.
It's just bizarre. All these people are like, "This This totally
changed. It's way different than before." No, it's
Except like except other people coming on. The content focus
is the same. We just have other people coming on before.
I I recall seeing a tweet where he said >> Or maybe he
did. So, is
Prior to the J Soc flop, yes.
This guy hated me from the This guy was a big Tom Foolery fan.
He's hated me forever. Why is he like, "Oh, I like J Soc until
he turned on Destiny."
hated me. Oh, yeah. Yeah, great point. >> he Is he culpable
So, under Oh, it is the [__] tribute guy. >> you'd
agree under that standard he's culpable for the harassment of
Ethan Klein. Is Destiny culpable? Yep. Uh
>> Any of these standards applied to any of these people.
It's so insane that we think of these are the standards.
Pisco been watching the content. Hammer
point. Thank you, Pisco. Continue to hammer this point that these
people are totally disingenuous. They're totally
They don't care about this. If they cared about it at all, they
wouldn't even know who we are because they wouldn't be watching
Destiny, okay? If they gave a [__] about any of the
things they profess to care about, they wouldn't even know who
we are cuz they would never been watching Destiny in the first
place to eventually trickle out into other communities surrounding
him. Wouldn't ever happened.
It's like this um, you want to talk
>> the double standard in the context of anti-Semitism.
Anti-Piscoism
is all built on double standards. [laughter] It's insane.
Insane. And but I'm the thing is when you have truth on your
side, when you have facts and logic on your side, you can walk
out with a pure heart and say, "Debate it. Anytime, any place,
get a moderator.
Bring the information if you want to go step by step on all the
videos, spend 8 hours on it. I'm here for it."
Yeah, okay. Um, as far as the rest of the anti-Semitism goes,
sorry, the other part of it cuz like there there are there's
a bunch of different factors that go into like like left-wing
anti-Semitism doesn't look like right-wing anti-Semitism and
I think that's probably why people are very
like they they're kind of taken aback by the notion of it because
right-wing anti-Semitism is very easy to identify. And usually
when people think of anti-Semitism, they think of Nick Fuentes.
They think of Jews who control the world. They think of you know,
like Germany and that kind of anti-Semitism.
Um, but I mean, yeah, left-wing anti-Semitism does involve issues
of >> Yeah, but I I want to say I'm very concerned by left-wing
anti-Semitism. I think it's growing. I think that there are multiple
instances of left-wing anti-Semitic violence that have occurred
in the US. I think that it's been a bipartisan consensus that
it's a problem. I agree it's a problem. I'm alarmed by it. I'm
alarmed at some of these anti-Semitic tropes like the Zog memes.
Um, I think that Wait, so do you think that what Elias Rodriguez
did when he went to that museum and and shot those two embassy
workers? Do you think that was anti- I'm also very alarmed at
how funny these anti-Semitic memes are, okay? I'm also alarmed
at how funny the Zog memes are, okay? It's my bad.
I'm very alarmed anti-Semitism
>> I'm alarmed by how humorous I find them, >> think
that was anti-Semitic. >> I definitely think that's anti-Semitic.
Okay, yeah, I figured that you would cuz like yeah, cuz like
he didn't like he went to a museum and he basically like he didn't
know those people worked at Right. So, so understand like I'm
an intention Wait, did they figure that out? Is that Is that
figured out? Did he mag dumped those people? I I think there's
a legitimate
argument that he did know. Wait, did know? Yeah, that he did
know. He was like gang stalking that whole realm. I don't Dude,
I think you got to look into this one. I don't think there's
ever been more information released. I am going to judge someone's
conduct and culpability and state of mind based on their intent.
So, we just had someone posted like the video of the guy running
over someone else. And I know just because these always go with
like the the guy the people are going to post a bunch of stuff
about his past and [__] The only thing that matters
is what the person knew at the time. And that's what's going
to Uh, the same thing by the way in terms of how I assess the
the plan to make the trap for the lawsuits. Now, you can come
up with this like
that oh, he changed his mind on the trap after he said it. And
so, it was informed by new things and [__]
I Okay, I do this too. I don't know if this is ever going to
be good in a given conversation.
Even though this is probably her position. I think there's a
90 Pisco is like 99% accurate with this. But people hate it when
you say something's their position, they haven't said it. Sure,
it may might have been informed by new things whatever. You have
to assess the moral ability of different stages.
But you need to work with what was apparent at the time
the actions took place to assess intent. Otherwise, you're you
know, with the
the uh the linearity of time in a way that is uh Yeah, okay.
I mean, basically like the the double standard aspect of it isn't
also just like you over focus on it. It's also that you feel
the need to Um even if you're even if you believe it, but like
somebody somewhere down the line must like know that they're
I I don't even know like what kind of views this comes from.
But there's this weird tendency um to to basically exaggerate
everything that Israel does to the point where like I mean, you
probably heard I had back when the Gaza wars first started, people
were talking about how Gaza was on the brink of famine and and
how like um Israel was starving people. I I I imagine like we've
heard that for like 2 years. And then Israel actually did start
starving people when like after Trump got elected and they cut
off all aid for like 3 months.
Uh he did know, he hung around the event and found out that they
worked at the embassy. How does this This happen crackhead I've
seen in my chat before. How does he know that?
How does he know that? And like they're actually and then like
actual organizations started reporting on famine. But prior to
that, you could see that there were definitely like lots of like
there were there were enough like aid trucks going in. The issue
was distribution. But people pinned it all on Israel. And like
or um this weird exaggeration. Like even one could argue that
like that the claim that they were committing genocide and there
were people who were saying they were committing genocide on
October 8th. Like I feel like that's kind of insane. It's like
this weird thing where you over focus specifically on Israel.
And it kind of makes people in Israel go, why why? Why is it
just us and not everybody else who's ever done bad [__]
that you're talking about? Or like why are we being held to this
insane high standard that you won't necessarily hold anybody
else to? Like I've had conversations with people who like I I
talked to like a a progressive person the other day who said
that like all of Israel's actions in Gaza are unacceptable because
because it's bad if a single civilian gets killed. The pager
attack was bad because because of like some civilians got killed
even though that was like um a very sort of proportionate attack.
But that that wasn't acceptable to them. I don't care if this
person's I don't think it makes a big difference. Because that
you know, like most of the people that were killed in that
Lots of white Zionists out there. I don't know if you guys know
that. Like Hezbollah operatives. I mean, those are the people
that were Hezbollah operatives. There there I think certainly
there's overlap between people who are against the state of Israel
and then I would even say some significant overlap. Um I would
say mean more than 5%. Uh that of people who are anti-Semitic
and are applying double standards that are justified in a differential
treatment based on that. But >> But yeah, but that I would
say that that's the left-wing anti-Semitism aspect of it. And
I feel like like you've run into that >> obligation for
any particular person before I'm willing to call them anti-Semitic,
I need to see more than just they're part of the group of
Okay, hold on. Watch this thing really quickly and then we're
going to go. Definitely being a bozo saying Dubious buying you
out or whatever. Steven's definitely being a bozo saying Dubious
buying you out or >> How about lying?
How about lies and lying?
That's how I would phrase it. Lying. Just straight up lies.
I don't know why we have to It's like weird how he does that
a quite a lot actually. It's It's weird how that's like something
so many different people are saying about this guy?
It's weird that like we can disagree on so many things and then
we're just like, oh, this guy's like lying. He's Oh, he's just
lying? Wow. Round up. Mary Box State, peace go.
All right. All
right.
All right, all right, all right.
I think that's it. I think that's it for the stream tonight.
What do I got on the clock? We probably went 8 hours, didn't
Yeah, we did. We went over 8 hours. All right, we're back.
We're back. Base stream tonight. Lots of people around. Lots
of people hanging
Good stream. Double stream.
We'll be back tomorrow.
All right?
sweet dreams. Have a good night. Be back
Yeah, I I think earlier, not 100%
but I think earlier, probably 6:30.
I'm not sure for 6:30. We'll see what happens, okay?
Okay, love you guys. Good night. Bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye.